most incubators don't work yeah and most
companies at incubators don't work and
so if you're looking for like next stage
in life if you make it work you'll have
unlimited opportunities to join other
incubators to start new incubators the
key is like make this one thing work for
the entrepreneurs coming in the biggest
thing to struggle with is closing sales
like they struggle with getting their
product it's one getting getting their
MVP like created and then bringing in
Revenue the business is shut down
because they can't generate sustainable
cash flow if you're in real estate you
understand the cash and sales yeah and
try to utilize the network is what
you're saying yeah so helping them get
to the point where they're at least
covering their costs so that they can
hang around long enough to blow up like
so many entrepreneurs are focused on I'm
gonna go change the world with my new
tech startup cool yeah let's get to the
point where you can stay sustainable
what I'm looking to do is is try to get
some more insight on
um a new role that I'm going to be
playing at a startup so that's why I
thought maybe it might be helpful more
with yourself it's not to do with
blogging or anything it's part of an
accelerator program so a little bit of
that is is getting out of my comfort
level and and being exposed to startups
but further wanting to learn you know
kind of I've read the book and
kind of need a little bit more help in
terms of being able to structure my
career path I'd say and and understand
how I can be of service to these
institutions based on the experience
I've have with 20 plus years in real
estate and what I'm going into is real
estate technology startups cool that's
one question that's kind of come up to
my in my head so what are you doing at
the incubator
I'm assisting um I'm actually co-running
it oh cool yeah it's with TMZ in our
neighborhood in Toronto oh you're in
Toronto cool I have uh out of uh Ryerson
well I don't even know what they call
themselves now but yeah Ryerson yeah
it's not rarest anymore yeah
Metropolitan University or University or
something yeah and so is that what you
want to do you want to like go co-found
more I'd like to I'd like to
um this is something new and you know
opportunities came about and something
I've been working on and it's taken
about two years to be able to find event
a VC to
um go back this and we're going to be
starting up uh in September I'm going to
be visiting the office later today
but that's something where I thought I
would be able to try to find out if I
can get some help from Zan or from you
just in terms of understanding again how
can I make an impact because a lot of
things you're seeing are are really
coming into into play here in terms of
being able to provide a service and
making sure that I have the opportunity
to grow and learn in that role
if that makes any sense
yeah most incubators don't work
yeah and most companies at incubators
don't work and so if you're looking for
like next stage in life and what to do
after like that if you make it work
you'll have unlimited opportunities
to to join other incubators to start new
incubators the key is like make this one
thing work right for the entrepreneurs
coming in they struggle with
um the biggest thing to struggle with is
closing sales like they struggle with
getting their product depending on what
stage but it's usually is an incubators
it's early stage it's early stage yeah
so like yeah it's one getting getting
their MVP getting their mineral viable
product like created and then bringing
in Revenue that the business is shut
down because they can't generate
sustainable cash flow right so right you
know if you're in real estate you
understand the cash on sales yeah and
try to utilize the network is what
you're saying yeah so so helping them
get to the point where they're at least
covering their costs so that they can
hang around long enough to blow up like
so many entrepreneurs are focused on I'm
gonna go change the world with my new
tech startup cool yeah let's get to the
point where you can stay sustainable
right what's what are those first sales
that we need to bring in and whether
that's you making introductions to
people
it's a big reason why people would join
an incubator yeah right you're going to
introduce them to somebody that's going
to help yeah or if you're gonna just
stay on them and train them like helping
them with their pitch helping them with
their decks helping them on the phone
helping them do the follow-ups helping
them become sales people a lot of tech
startups suck at sales because they're
yeah that's what I'm finding you know
but they did enough to get into into the
incubator so they sold themselves enough
to get in there so there's they've got
something but it's that combination of
of the training to do better sales
um even the accountability like if you
if you uh help them stay entrepreneurs
suck with accountability
right yeah so like they say they're
gonna do something and they don't do it
see Evan
um or are you saying that's me I don't
know no no I'm writing this down now I
haven't had his hand up um but
entrepreneurs suck with accountability
especially at the beginning when they
have no idea then this is their first
thing so
helping them with that like coming in
and setting what's what's our sales plan
guys
what's our what
what's our sales plan yeah right and
then helping them actually create one
and stick to it and making sure that
they're doing the thing that they said
they were going to do not just going
into the tech that they love geeking out
over and you helping make introductions
for them
allows them to have success which then
allows the incubator to have success
which then allows you to go wherever you
want to go afterwards
got it yeah it's helpful I appreciate
that
yeah
um there's the whole motivation side so
they keep bringing guest speakers and
all that kind of stuff but really it's
like get the get them to a sustainable
business and then get them to to going
off and changing the world
and and sales playing in the
introductions so like for every business
identify their ideal clients and then
yeah your network and also friends of
friends who might be able to come in and
either buy from them or at least give
them honest feedback of of where they're
falling down like people will take a
meeting because they love supporting the
the university and they love supporting
the incubators right you take the
meeting if you reach out and it may not
become a client but at least you get
really good feedback
and they may not know how to do that so
if you spent you know
half an hour a week with everybody
trying to help them make those
introductions
some of those will hit and you'll end up
really having a lot of success there and
then that's it you just have to make
that one work
and then you could be the incubator Guru
and go around the world doing it like
most of them fail so yeah so in this one
it's interesting because I've got we're
being backed up by a large pension fund
so that's going to be a bit of a live
case study in terms of the companies or
two or three companies that we choose
out of that incubator to work on lean on
them
okay lean on the investors and say hey
we've got a tech startup inside computer
peripherals or whatever we need we need
to get to these guys like every company
in their sales plan that comes through
you needs to make a list of their top 50
clients that they want to talk to and
you might know some of them already cool
and if not you lean on you talk to the
pension fund hey we need to talk to
whoever's in charge of tech at Royal
Bank
do you know anybody yeah okay got it
yeah I know where you come from is there
anything that you recommend I I read
any of your material or anything in
terms of because this is kind of really
pretty much what you are doing in terms
of helping the startups as well
um
I don't have a lot of good books direct
I don't really read a lot of books I
mean build to serve is great
good one required reading at the
incubator
um but honestly it's just
you just have to be a resource for them
like help them get sales
like if they're coming in they probably
already have a mission then they're
probably working on their Tech but like
how do they commercialize this and if
you have big uh like the pension fund
that's involved in in your thing cool
they're investing into tons of companies
like the amount they're investing in you
is so small compared to their entire
portfolio the problem is most people are
not most of their portfolios are not
reaching out asking for help
and they have a deep network of people
so you reach out and say hey we need to
get to whoever runs Tech at Royal Bank
to get feedback on this can you help us
yeah I hear you so you're saying
leverage dmz's resources to our
advantage and network yeah they're like
the resources as a network yeah exactly
The Tech Guys need to know the like the
com the startup companies need to know
how to create their thing
create the product or service but right
the network to get it into the hands so
it's commercializable that needs to be
pulling on DMZ pulling on all the
investors and that could be you to help
be the liaison for that
and maybe they say no cool but most
people aren't even asking yeah yeah
you're right no that's not the guy who
appreciate it yeah
cool thank you you got it
um
there you go
but you know what this is very meta this
is very meta like what Zen just did here
it you were acting like most of the
companies in your incubator Act yep
you're right hidden camera off not
asking questions but needing help or
like that's everybody who's coming
through your company
they don't want to turn the camera on
and ask for help and and talk about
their business because they'd rather
just stay tinker and attack and what Zen
said like hey come on and ask this
question
and hopefully you get no it I could have
not picked you I could have said no
screw this guy without his camera on I
could have like not given you good
advice but at least you took the shot
right yeah no I agree you need to be the
Zen for everybody who comes in and help
open up even if like Zan didn't have the
answer to this question he would have
answered some other way but the way he
didn't have the answer but he
facilitated the connection that's all
you need to do you may not have the
answer to who runs Tech at Royal Bank
but you can facilitate the connection
with these people so they can start to
grow got it it's awesome thank you cool
thanks man there you go thank you Zan
that's what it's all about
the first question that came in on the
poll was how can we focus on one thing
with too much information
so at the beginning of anything
it always can feel overwhelming right if
you're thinking about I want to start on
YouTube I want to start on social media
I want to start writing my book I want
to start like whatever new project you
want to start it always feels
overwhelming it always feels like it's
too big it always feels like you don't
have enough information you can't wrap
your head around what's going on and so
what I like to do is just trying to
figure out where are the boundaries like
what is it that I actually need to learn
and at the beginning I get super
frustrated of any project
just trying to figure out where are the
gates because I'm I love optimizing I
love efficiency I love making things as
tight as possible but at the beginning
creativity is messy and you can't
prematurely optimize something we try to
optimize too soon when you don't know
the boundaries you end up not being able
to make any progress so at the beginning
of any project I will take some time sit
in my frustration and just basically try
to figure out where the gates are around
it so what's the most recent one I think
um figuring out AdWords and advertising
has been one of those things for me in
figuring out okay what ads do I run how
do I put them up what are the placements
what what's the conversions uh the
demographics you know all of the things
that
seem overwhelming at the beginning and
it's frustrating to know which ads to
serve to which
um audiences and just testing tests and
testing testing until I kind of get a
sense of okay this is where the gates
are and then
make it efficient and squish it down and
optimize it
um so at the beginning for me it's just
research right research plane testing
find don't get so overwhelmed by the the
big picture that you don't take any
action right like what's the smallest
possible thing you can just do to start
gaining momentum and then
that first step seems impossible but
when you go back it's like oh I did that
I did that first step that's pretty cool
now it's Evan Evan's holding up to two
percent I got mine I got mine too make
the two percent happen anyway so I hope
that makes sense right it's taking that
big idea that seems overwhelming that
seems impossible and then finding one
step that you can do today because as
long as you have it as some big dream in
your head that is impossible then you
never take any action and then you know
it's a year later and you still haven't
done the thing yet because it still
seems too impossible and I see it all
the time with entrepreneurs who are
getting started people ask you how do I
get started on YouTube how do I get
started as an author how do I get
started as a speaker and and you think
you've got to have this perfect plan and
the perfect gear and all of this perfect
stuff and then it's a year later and you
still haven't done the thing immediate
action momentum I see Zayn's big smiling
um Dan joined me on my uh three days a
week now I stream League of Legends and
answer business questions and Zen joined
in and they said yeah I'm gonna start
making YouTube videos uh and I think it
was original timeline was like next
month or in two months or something it's
like dude Zen come on tonight make a
video let's go get get your video up uh
and then he did and he got his first
video up and then the second video and
then another video like he's got his
phone out he's gonna make another video
right now
like that's the process and and it's not
gonna be perfect being off your phone
and it's and it's not gonna be the the
lighting that you want or the gear that
you want or the background that you want
and your thoughts may not come out as
clearly as you want that's the beginning
like the beginning is supposed to be
messy so don't stress out about having
all the information at the beginning
just go just create like in that
momentum uh you will start getting some
results
um and additional momentum to keep on
building right and
I think a lot of you know my story about
losing that 40 million deal when I was
22 years old of just trying to be too
perfect and have it all planned out and
you know
going to Market and then seeing Oh My
Perfect plan was not what people wanted
anyway right like your perfect version
of a YouTube video is not going to be
perfect anyway once you start creating
it's going to change it's going to take
a million different turns
um so the best way to do it is to do it
so to take action against that big idea
so it doesn't just stay
uh doesn't just State an idea for you
forever okay next question Nicolette
said what is your advice on where to
start with content creation if you
haven't started at all
so the easiest place to start is
actually Instagram stories like easy is
easiest easiest way to start is
Instagram stories it's on Instagram
they're 15 seconds Max it's it's meant
to be informal it's meant to be
non-edited it's meant to be kind of
behind the scenes and so if you're
trying to develop that practice of being
a speaker of creating content I
recommend starting like Ground Zero you
start with Instagram stories and try to
find three to ten moments during the day
that you can share you know you where's
my book built the serve right you guys
you guys you have this book if you're in
this group right you've you've got it
hopefully you've read it it's not just
some fancy ornament sitting there on
your desk Zane's got two copies Victor's
got his copy
I love it Evans I know has got an entire
Shelf full of uh of books somewhere
there at the top
um
so you know it's it's about starting to
share the way that you think to serve
other people you you're weird you're
different you're I like to say you're a
weird duck you think differently your
job is to teach me to think like you
think so some of the things that may
seem super obvious to you for other
people is not so obvious right if I look
at even your your rooms for those of you
who I can see you know your your rooms
like why does Zan have Captain America
shield on his wall you know why does
Evan have Napoleon Hill on his wall and
Andrew Carnegie Doug's Doug's trying to
hold up built to serve but it's being
blocked out by then by the Florida coast
uh you know why does Jeff have Steve
Jobs up on his wall right Michael's
showing believe up on his wall right
like why why do you have these in your
rooms in your offices it means something
to you and that may be like maybe maybe
Zan's been a Captain America fan since
he was eight years old I don't know like
maybe that's just so natural normal for
him but for other people it's kind of
weird to have a Captain America shield
on your door right like most people
don't have that so explain why it's
there right explain why you pick up this
book most people wouldn't know that
that's Napoleon Hill up on Evan's wall
right so explain why he's there explain
what that message means and finding
these micro moments throughout the day
from your your routines your habits what
you're eating for lunch what happened
when a client emailed you like the way
you respond to things is different and
so that's your job it's not about how
fancy the the video footage is it's your
job to teach me to think the way that
you think and sometimes this is hard to
step out of because for you it's so
natural and normal because you've been
doing it for a long time but for
somebody else who's watching you from
the outside it's it's weird and
different and that's the whole point and
so Instagram stories I think is the
easiest way to start just to get you
into that practice of creating content
again you know three to ten different
stories a day it takes 15 seconds Max so
you know at the minimum I'm asking for
45 seconds a day right this is not a
groundbreaking amount of time to create
content right 45 seconds three 15 second
stories a day
when you're ready to jump in and make it
much bigger
I would look at YouTube as my primary
home and then I would split up the
content to go to the different platforms
so when you can get to making one
YouTube video per week I want a 10
minute YouTube video every week and it
could just be taking me deeper right Zan
has a 10 minute story about the Captain
America shield Evan has a 10-minute
story about what he's learned from
Napoleon Hill Jeff has a 10 minute story
about what that Bullseye thing is behind
him right you know Michael has a
10-minute story about what believe means
to him right it's it's just taking me
deeper into it but the the Instagram
content stories is the first way to just
start practicing getting it
out of your head out of your mouth and
into the internet right into the world
um once you can get to 10 minute video a
week that's where I want you to be on
YouTube
because those that content will live
forever and then you split up the
content to go to all the different
social media platforms so until you're
ready to do that Instagram stories once
you're ready to do that then you can
still do the Instagram stories right
it's just add-on it's additive again the
Instagram stories are 45 seconds a day
everybody here has 45 seconds today to
record three Instagram stories to tell
me about something that's happening in
your life and and it's not this is
really hard for me at the beginning of
making content was it's not about
uh
telling me what you ate for lunch and
just kind of vlogging
it's trying to find a message in
everything so if you're showing me your
lunch tell me why you picked that thing
like why are you picking asparagus for
lunch or why are you having that Donut
for lunch like why why are you picking
that thing like explain to me the
thought process behind it right I'm
having the donut because I'm celebrating
my 50th birthday or something right like
I'm getting the asparagus because I have
you know I want to live a keto lifestyle
or whatever it is right like explain the
thought process behind the decisions I
remember when I first got started on
social Twitter was was blowing up and I
thought Twitter was stupid like this
looks so stupid people are just sharing
pictures of their lunch and cats and I
have no interest in just sharing I'm a
pretty uh private person believe it or
not like I have no need for you to know
what's happening in my life I have no
need to share it
but when I realized oh this is actually
thought leadership content that the
reason behind making this book or the
reason behind having these pictures on
my wall it's not about me showing off
it's about me trying to help other
people think the way I think so that
they can improve their lives as well so
everything you've got around you is a
story that hopefully has helped you
improve your life some way now bring
that back to bring not bring that back
into the audience so that they can learn
from you like why are you here why did
you pick up build to serve what was the
biggest lesson that you got from it all
of these could be individual stories
that again teaches people to think like
you think so Stephen wrote why is it
important to tell your story Okay so
and built the serve we talked about this
right
people need to connect to you
if they don't feel like you know what
they've gone through they won't listen
to you so
you know Evan has shared a lot about his
story with uh alcohol addiction and
you know you would look at Evan like
right now and you would say oh this guy
looks like he's polished and clean and
knows what he's doing and has his life
in order and you wouldn't necessarily
think that he was addicted to alcohol
and and I know Evan's okay with me kind
of sharing bits of his story here on the
Stream
so if somebody came and was struggling
with alcohol addiction and they came
across Evan and he said hey here's what
you have to do these three things
they say yeah that's great man but you
don't know what I've been through
you don't know what it's like you don't
you don't I mean I'm addicted you look
at you you've got your life together
it's all sorted out meanwhile Evan knows
exactly what it's like uh to contemplate
suicide to to be you know massively
addicted to have a lot of self-hatred
because of of the addiction of that
cause
and so unless people know what you've
been through they won't listen to your
advice like Evan has some of the best
advice to help people overcome it but
unless they know his story about how he
came through that they won't listen to
him
because people will naturally think well
you don't know what I'm going through
and so this is where you have to share
your story where you've came from even
the journey that you're still on right
we're still growing we're still learning
we're never done learning growing
getting better and improving but where
did you struggle where did you come from
because ultimately your purpose like we
talked about and built the serve is to
help other people who currently are who
you used to be
right there are many people who are Evan
from eight years ago
I have intense we got two evidence in
the group I like using that as an
example right but there's also many
people who are having Carmichael from
eight years ago and that's who you're
talking to and that's who you'll love
helping the most you know Evan tinsman
will love helping anybody right and he's
been uh an amazing human in in the
movement makers group in this group even
when we first did our session in
Pittsburgh uh he was bringing value to
all the other people in the room he just
wants to help right he wants to
contribute which is fantastic
but helping somebody who
is currently struggling through alcohol
addiction is currently struggling with
self-worth is currently struggling with
uh potential you know suicide he'll love
helping those people more than holding
the door for somebody at a grocery store
or buying a Starbucks the person behind
him in line because that's who he used
to be and it's the same thing for all of
you and I'm telling I'm a story because
I know it better I don't know all of
your stories you know in detail but
you've all been through something
and those are the people who you're
going to love helping out the most it
just feels so much better it feels so
fulfilling that you represent hope to
them that when they see you
and what you've come through
it represents possibility for them
because they don't see possibility for a
lot of you where you are right now is
impossible
for where Evan is right now it's
impossible he shouldn't be here he
shouldn't be doing the stuff that he's
doing right now it's impossible Evan
from X number of years ago would look at
this kind say there's no way you're
going to be doing that that's not
possible
but he did it yeah and so have you and
all of you are here right now and the
version of you five ten years ago would
say that's not possible and so that's
your job is to show other people who
currently are you from five or ten years
ago that it's possible that there is
hope that you can grow that you can
overcome that you can climb out of this
hole that you're in
but without sharing your story to the
question that Stephen asked without
sharing your story
uh nobody's gonna listen to you so
you've got all this great information
you've got the knowledge the tools the
the desire to help the willingness all
of it and you can help and you know that
it can help
but nobody's going to listen to you
because they feel like you don't know
what you're talking about because you
haven't been through what I've been
through right
so that's why it's super important to
share your story and and
um it's scary
it's scary to share your story it's
scary to put it out there it's scary for
people to know
um what you've been through you know
like using Evan against an example he's
has a super successful uh practice uh in
insurance and it could be scary to let
that out to have clients have customers
have Partners have people in the
community know that you almost killed
yourself and you were addicted to
alcohol right like now you're not normal
anymore now you don't fit in maybe as
much anymore it could be scary for
people to know what you've been through
um
but if you are silent it perpetuates a
silence it means everybody else who's
struggling with it they stay silent too
and they become afraid to share and your
willingness to share to be brave to be
courageous to put your story out there
inspires other people to say hey I'm not
alone I'm not the only one going through
this and it's okay to share my story too
so I see that as your all of you your
responsibility to be able to do that so
okay Esmeralda is here how do I overcome
the fear of being in front of the camera
or sharing pictures of myself well
where's Esmeralda Esmeralda we could do
it right now it's called turning on your
camera
hey we got lots of people hey there she
is Esmeralda
it's one step look at all the high fives
and fist bumps and flexes you're getting
right I mean that's that's the start
uh so I do a couple of things one
is I tell myself that being afraid is
not a good enough reason
you don't want to teach yourself that
I'm afraid and I don't do it I'm afraid
and I play small I'm afraid to chase
down my dream and then I don't go for it
because that becomes this negative cycle
that we repeat and I love that you're
like in a in a grocery store or
convenience store somewhere there well
they're all still tuning in to the live
it's amazing uh but being afraid is not
a good enough reason if you can catch it
like the reason I want to do this but
I'm but I'm afraid that just mental
break down that wall being afraid is no
longer a good enough reason because
everything that you want out of life is
on the other side of what you're afraid
of
every growth every opportunity every
breakthrough every client like
everything you want to do comes from
doing things that you're afraid of
otherwise if you're never afraid then
what then you
you stay stuck doing what you're doing
you just stay inside your comfort zone
it's just your life photocopying every
single day
are you at your job that's amazing I
think she's working there it's awesome
Esmeralda joining in
I remember when I had my one of the only
jobs I had was doing data entry at this
company and they wouldn't let me listen
to music so it was back when we had a CD
what's a CD man it's like the Walkman
but for CDs like a portable little CD
player so I used to have that on the
floor and then I ran a wire through my
jeans and I always wore a turtleneck and
I ran I got an extra long extension cord
for my headset for my headphones and I'd
run the wire under my turtleneck and
just pop out here to get one little
sound Bud to go into my ears so I can
listen to some uh mostly Andrea Bocelli
at the time while I was doing this super
boring data entry work so I love it I
love I love the hacks
um okay so to that question one is
fear alone is not a good enough reason
the second part is you're trying to
serve you're trying to serve you want to
help you're doing this you know you're
afraid to get in front of the camera but
why do you want to get in front of the
camera
take it from I want to it's not about
you being seen it's not about you being
this big famous name it's about you have
a message that can help people you're
here trying to serve and whenever I flip
it to it's about the audience it's about
the people who will see this is that
even if only five people see this video
maybe two out of those five people this
could actually be something
life-changing for them
it's not about you it's about them
that always gives me that extra little
bit of of confidence and push to go off
and do the thing that that I'm afraid to
do so I balance it between those two
things right I'll tell myself I'm Evan
christili Carmichael I do difficult
things or I do scary things or I do the
things I'm afraid of Plus
I'm here to serve and I'm here to help
and my message
can hopefully Touch Somebody Today it
may not but it's your intention going in
like the intention behind the action of
being in front of the camera is not to
screw people over it's not just to make
yourself famous it's to try to help is
to try to serve
and so I always take that mindset going
in before uh whenever I'm super nervous
uh or before never making any piece of
content it helps when you're when you're
even filming your own YouTube videos
because sometimes it's hard when you're
at home in an office maybe with Corona
you haven't seen any humans for the last
little bit and interact with them and
you just even here I'm talking just into
a camera and it's awesome to be able to
see your faces up here on the screen
to remind yourself that hey this is a
video that's not just me in my office by
myself you're making this video to try
to touch somebody else's life and when
you take that as an intention your video
will be better
when you just focused on oh am I looking
at the camera and is my mic set up and
all this other stuff your video won't be
as good compared to if you actually
picture somebody
in your head I used to do this all the
time because I had a hard time getting
to the zone and I was making content I
would picture somebody and I'm I'm
making this video for him this video is
just for him and I'm speaking to him and
and that would Channel him as I pressed
record on my camera and I'd always end
up getting a much better video man time
flies it's crazy we've already got time
let's get to let's get to like super
rapid fire
uh uh how to deliver the idea message in
a simple way
uh oh hot chocolate readings I would I
would do a 30 second hot chocolate
reading every day and post it to
Instagram
hot chocolate reading of the day and
then whatever whatever the whatever
comes at every day right every day for
30 seconds
um from Denise what type of videos go
viral in your opinion if you know if I
had a recipe for making a viral video
every time
that'd be amazing like that's what
everybody's going after but really be
looking at
make the video that you from five years
ago badly needs right make the video
that the you from five or ten years ago
badly means because the youth from five
or ten years ago probably wouldn't watch
an Evan Carmichael video
like oh that guy he's too energetic he's
too positive that can't be real I don't
know
you know like you don't want to listen
to those guys
but
you could you could touch you from five
or ten years ago in a way that Evan
Carmichael or Tony Robbins or Brendan
Bouchard or whoever else can't
and that's I think even much more
important than worrying about a viral
video that that blows up on the Internet
is having an impactful video that
changes somebody's life
so I'm still trying to make the content
that
uh that I need right now but also that
like five years ago Evan still needs uh
so that's always kind of in the back of
my head as well
I haven't since been saying disagree ooh
okay your content helped get this Evan
to where he is now well I love it thank
you everyone appreciate the love man
um loved that five to ten years ago idea
brilliant yeah just to imagine you from
five or ten years ago or somebody who is
like you and you're making content for
that person because you know again Jeff
from five or ten years ago is thinking a
different way he's not doesn't have as
much of a growth mindset is
not wanting to listen to a lot of the
messages that are being put up there you
know he would look at what you're doing
now so that's crazy you know with books
on the shelf and Bullseye and all these
goals and accomplish like you wouldn't
think that that would be possible uh and
so you can reach Jeff from five or ten
years ago in a way that nobody else can
the poll question was from Michael who
said owning your time and schedule so
my quick take on this and then we'll get
the you know questions from you guys
whatever I can help answer in this
little mini break for us today
um I love energy zones I think I think
staying in the same energy Zone really
really matters so today is Thursday uh
all of my public facing stuff is on a
Thursday I had I start with movement
makers which always gets me I'm an
introvert right so I don't wake up and
like hey Michael Jordan just in time
we're doing your question right now
Michael drive safe though drive safe
um we uh you know I get so much love
from Movie Makers that that gets me
fired up for the rest of the day and so
all I have to do on a Thursday is do my
public facing stuff so all day long it's
just interviews and and sessions like
this and podcasts and at a movie makers
and then three podcasts and then this
and then like four more podcasts and
then live streaming tonight but I'm not
worried about my YouTube channel I'm not
worried about my team I'm not worried
about anything else besides just
spreading the message today and I think
it's great to stay in that energy Zone
because the energy I got from Movie
Makers I'm still pouring into the next
group and the love I get from you guys
I'm pointing to my podcast right after
this and so I don't have to switch I
think switching between different tasks
ends up being really really it's
challenging for everybody maybe extra
challenging for me
um because I think to spend half an hour
on a podcast and then 20 minutes writing
the book and then 40 minutes doing
something else you end up just getting
nothing done you feel like if you ever
felt like I worked all day but I got
nothing done
it's probably because you're switching
between energy states too much and so
all I have to worry about today is this
one thing of spreading the message
um
yesterday was my project day
so this this is a change that I made in
the past year or year and a half that
really made a huge impact was adding
project day in the middle so Tuesday
Wednesday Thursday Tuesday is my YouTube
day it's crazy it's crazy it's just I
gotta make videos for 12 different
channels plus two strategy plus it's
just all day long if you're on my team
don't try to reach me on a Tuesday it's
not going to happen I'm just making
videos
Thursdays today is crazy crazy just all
day long interviews and podcasts and
Skypes and just all day long
so in the middle Wednesday is open day
Wednesday is my project day Wednesday I
wake up I'm like what do I want to work
on today
um it doesn't turn into like let's play
League of Legends all day like I like
working but I get to basically pick
whatever project I want to work on and I
like having a freedom
in the middle of the week between the
two crazy days it used to be like write
my book day right you know if I'm
writing the book I need a whole day it's
hard to write a book in 20 minutes a day
because it takes you 20 minutes just to
get back into what you were doing any
kind of creative work if you're doing
creative work you need like chunks of
time without the stress of I need to be
done by one o'clock so I can go off and
do this thing that kills your creativity
so Wednesday's creative work day
um and and I'm just trying to get way
way way way way way more stuff done
working the same number of hours but
just way more productive because I'm not
shifting my energy too much now you may
not be in complete control of your day
you might have a job you might have
customers you might have other
responsibilities family whatever so
whatever is inside your calendar that
you can control just being more
intentional with it
and making sure that what's in your
calendar is going to help you get your
goals right like if you want to have a
YouTube channel I was talking about just
before this was on a podcast with the
guys like help me build my YouTube
channel okay great well show me where in
your calendar have you dedicated time to
make YouTube videos
oh I haven't done that well that's why
you're not making YouTube videos dude
it doesn't ever happen it's like yeah
that's why I haven't made a video in the
past three months okay great so it's
it's we can change that we can add that
we can put it in
um but your actions have to be you know
map to your Ambitions what's in your
calendar has to be the thing that you're
working towards every day so I like
different days for different things I
have my morning routine which I do every
day and then I fall into whatever that
day is going to be so mentoring day
Monday YouTube day Tuesday uh
Wednesday's open project Day creative
day Thursdays public facing day
interviews Friday is CEO day grow the
business Saturday is fun day
and then Sunday's family at midday and
even that's an important distinction
Sunday is
go grocery shopping do the laundry
uh
uh whatever I mean whatever has to get
done clean up the condo
you know all the all the stuff that you
have to do to live life that is not fun
but that's kind of required be honest on
a Sunday but it's not on Saturday
I'm not folding laundry on a Saturday
Saturday is the only day where we don't
even do I don't even do the dishes you
normally my wife cooks and I do the
dishes after not Saturday Saturday
I'll leave the dishes for Sunday
like Saturday is fun day and it's
important I think to put up the the
blocks on your calendar to more than not
just like what you are going to do but
what you're not going to do
I'm not going to
get interrupted by my team today I am
not going to work on my YouTube channel
today I am not going to and I think that
that really helps you stay a lot more
focused
and then my last is quick thought and
then we can open up if you want me to go
in deeper and Michael know you're here
so if you got questions on that this is
kind of top level but it also lets you
miss the work I like to miss the work
like you guys we see each other once a
week now it's like I miss you guys in
between
yeah it's like we get this and then
tomorrow I'm not missing you but then
come like Tuesday Wednesday like when we
get the reader's group and then Thursday
comes you're like Hey we're back
and so if you only do something once a
week you're always missing it when it
comes up
so I haven't made YouTube videos since
Tuesday I'm not missing it yet but come
like Friday Saturday it's like oh I want
to make I want to make some YouTube
videos so whatever day I'm about to jump
into I'm always missing the work as
opposed to kind of getting bored or
overwhelmed or whatever from it
um so that's really helped me and again
you may not be able to control your
whole day
but whatever you can control just being
intentional with it and asking yourself
hey over the next week I've got seven
days and inside inside of that I've got
14 hours that I can play with how am I
going to use those 14 hours
that are my time to be able to move
closer to achieving the goals I've got
for myself
that's my quick my quick take Michael to
help or you guys got extra questions you
want to dive deeper on it I got another
question
can I ask yeah yeah Michael then we'll
go to we'll go to Nile that's how his
hand up too what do you got okay uh uh
so at the end of the day do you have a
time that you stop with your work and
then that's your family time time to
spend with your kid uh or with the wife
or are you like until you go to bed uh
like you're on making videos until 8 p.m
and then you do your bedtime routine and
go to bed
so if I look at a normal breakdown
um with kind of family time so we'll
I'll go for a walk with my wife in the
morning so I'll take the dogs out then
we'll go for a walk and we spend the
first 45 minutes to an hour of the day
kind of just setting up for the day
we're both not mourning people so at the
beginning we're not really talking
it's kind of like holding hands and
walking outside
uh and then as like the Sun hits you and
the fresh air we start
having a conversation hey how's it
what's up for today how'd you sleep last
night and just kind of I like walking in
the day with some fresh air and not just
being inside all the time
um especially now with everything going
on it's like we don't get enough
outside stuff that we get to do
um then usually we'll take a break at 2
30.
uh we both have that in our calendar
there's a break for half an hour 2 30 to
connect it could be
um
depending on how we're feeling it could
be another like quick outside just take
the dog to the park super quick come
back up but that kind of built into our
schedule
um
after that I'll go back to work uh
usually until at least five five to six
is like my buffer zone for anything
urgent
so
you know today is my interview day I
actually have a gap from five to six but
I put that in because we booked so far
in advance for guests for my me to be on
shows that if something really urgent
comes up I hate having to post postpone
somebody or cancel on somebody like
worst case we can but if some big
opportunity comes up we have that as our
buffer zone just kind of like hotels off
in the the penthouse suite is open just
in case some big person comes in there's
there's a room for them they have to
kick somebody out
um six to seven thirty ish I'm doing my
live stream usually four days a week
with Zan here and and Drew and then from
7 30 to what nine
uh it's usually playing with the kids
uh right now we're doing a lot of
Minecraft together uh because three
different cities you know nieces nephews
all that stuff we just join on a
Minecraft server together I'm not very
good at Minecraft
um but whatever it's a fun thing to do
and I think there's a lot of actual life
lessons that happen like if you go and
you build your character in Minecraft
and then you step into lava and you lose
all your stuff do you rage quit and
freak out or can you talk that through
right and like I think you can parent
and teach and life lessons through
everything and the more you're doing
things that they like as opposed to like
forcing to do what you want
um there's actually better teaching
there
nine to ten Nina and I usually watch a
show right now we're watching Homeland
uh we're on the last season of Homeland
working our way through usually we're
watching like some of the superhero
movies or shows uh
Legends of tomorrow and what else we
watch Green Arrow
uh anyway there was this big gap of no
shows coming out it's like oh we got
nothing to watch so we fell into home
line and that's pretty good
um but that's one hour
then I wash the dishes take the dogs out
um answer the questions I do like 10
questions 11. and then we get ready for
bed
um
so that's a typical like Monday to
Friday kind of day Friday night would
probably just stay up a little bit later
and do stuff together but that's a
typical weekday so uh there's a morning
time there's an afternoon time when
there's an evening time
um spread out between like just the two
of us or time with family too so far
works but it's constant like Minor
Adjustments as we go Nile what you got
hey can you hear me today yeah we got
you yeah excellent yes hey your wall is
basically the same as mine dude it's
just it's it's orange I don't mine's
orange I know yours is coming through
with red I love you yours it kind of
looks red just a little lighter but I
like it dude this is great yeah thanks
and listen I have been I haven't had a
chance to speak this is fantastic at
what you're doing here and um I think
this is great and everything that people
share is fantastic you mind if I take it
off topic just for a little bit from the
scheduling or do you want to focus on
whatever whatever you guys want one
quick question I had was what would you
suggest or what's your thought on
building a brand on you as a person
compared to building a brand around an
entity or a company name or a theme
person's always easier okay your story
is your greatest Advantage right why is
somebody going to buy from you versus
some giant Corporation because they feel
like you actually care about them
but where you lose is you don't have the
history you don't have the reputation
you don't have the name brand yet you
think about whoever the biggest
competitors are in your industry like
why it's the old expressive nobody got
fired for buying IBM
um like the big brands that they're
trusted so they may not treat you super
well but at least you know what you're
getting and they have a history and
they're likely not going to screw you
over
um so if you're if you're a logo
you're basically taking the worst of
Both Worlds where if you make it your
personal brand they may not they may not
know you yet but it's like man this guy
cares
that's why sharing your story right I
mean
why emphasize so much in here is sharing
your story matters is what makes people
connect to you that okay maybe you don't
have the history of the reputation yet
but man I feel like this guy actually
cares about me and I wanna I wanna
I want to do business with him and how
about it sorry how if the theme itself
uh Builds on and stems from my story and
how I could further serve that's that's
where I'm thinking of going I've just
reincarnated myself but I rebranded
myself but it wasn't it's not me
necessarily it's me I'm all that's on on
my branding but it's backed by a mantra
and that that has to tie to your your
purpose of course yeah that's why you
tell your story because that's who
you're trying to help in reading your
story I need to feel like oh my God this
guy gets me right this guy is exactly
who I am and I need I need his help like
you're you're a hundred steps ahead but
you're the same person and so I can
learn from you because
you get me that's your biggest Advantage
your story is your biggest Advantage as
an entrepreneur right right I just
didn't know if it would be possession
from hey Nile it's me or the concept of
my brand not the concept but the
positioning of my brand so it it opens
up something that becomes familiar
um very similar to your your one word
that's that's where yeah like you are
your brand right right so it's not this
isn't this is what happened with your
one word and then build the service
believe isn't just a strategy for me
I am believe it's my who same thing for
all you guys like when you figure out
your who it's who you are and you show
up
everywhere as that so I I right now I'm
believing in you guys and I'm believing
all the people that I'm doing shows with
afterwards but when I when I come home
and still believe it's still spreading
belief to my wife and my family it's it
takes on a different life right I'm not
telling Nina go make your YouTube
content and spread your message but it's
still you know believing in her so it's
not just a hat that you wear it's
actually who you are so Nile equals
blank not just oh this is my business
stands for this but I stand for
something different
right perfect thank you
varindra yeah yeah and that's right
thank you thank you thank you for having
these sessions you are wonderful to have
you thanks a lot first of all and uh hi
everyone my question is on this point
you just mentioned about the one word so
I got your one word book now so reading
through it but if you get kind of help
in terms of how we find it and will be
uh you know get that through quickly so
we can start more
did you go through the five questions
of like your favorite teacher I I have
just started reading you yesterday of me
so I have got to that point the chapter
two where the five questions are there
so I'll be going to answer them okay so
that that honestly that's the best thing
like go through the questions the both
books were not designed as just uh
read the book and put it away it's like
it's it's a you have to think you have
to do the exercises you know it's a it's
almost a workbook inside a book
um if you want to get the value out of
it I think the best thing is go through
the questions and if you get stuck
come back next week and and we'll
Workshop it
okay yeah fine thank you
I saw a lady had her hand up lady Alexey
I'm trying to figure out how to work my
schedule uh as in uh recording videos
and all the other stuff ever since I've
been dealing with the death of my mom
and my kids and I'm swamped by
whether it's an appointment with the
attorney cleaning up the house
um you name it real estate agents of
course my brother my sister but you know
I have limited amount of energy I have
to juggle through it all so you were
talking about your schedule during the
day and I'm like okay how would I be
able to maintain some sort of schedule
uh along with the regular clients I've
got and and trying to get my story
online that's actually why I didn't
record because I was so tired at night
so you know there are moments where you
need to give yourself more grace right
and and you know sorry to hear about
your mom and your cat and
um you know we lost our family dog uh
not too long ago and
uh some people you know see that as
mushy or whatever but that's a big deal
like it's part of your family
um we also lost uh my sister-in-law last
year at the end of the year
um like 40 years old I did some super
rare cancer three kids
um one teen and two pre-teens and that
uh
that took us all out
you know I was not being nearly as
productive as I could have been
um
uh I wasn't doing as many shows as I
usually had my Wednesday or Friday might
have been completely gone instead of
doing creative work I'm spending the
time with my nieces or nephews just
not even doing much is being with them
because their mom just died and what do
you do as an eight-year-old right just
to have some kind of
love their um they're still you know
they were trying to figure out school or
no school and just dealing with it
um so this Grace you know there are some
moments in life where you have to give
yourself a little bit more grace and
understand that you're not going to be
at your regular capacity when I broke my
neck you know
that was brutal
but I still made videos every day you
know I think like having something that
you can hang your hat on to
to even if you're even if you're tired
even if you're not 100 just to look back
and say like I'm still not giving up on
my ambitions
so whatever that looks like for you like
if making videos is really important to
you I would still make videos and post
like you can make a five minute video I
made a video from my hospital bed with
my broken neck and a concussion
and
Doug Wilder is not here in the house
right now but he took a screenshot of it
and it looks like I'm dead
I mean it's probably just a bad
screenshot too but I've got my neck
brace on like this giant scab across my
forehead and it was definitely not
anywhere close to being my best content
but I'm you know looking back super
proud that I still did it
to do the difficult thing when it's hard
it was my best content it was a five
minute video instead of I committed to
going live every day
right while I was on my tour and
everybody
yeah
so it's it's okay to to let go of the
structure you know with opinion and all
that stuff and just post like one minute
videos and
you know without the beginning and the
ends you know the bumper and food are
let go of all that
at the end of the day
all that matters is how proud are you of
yourself
are you proud that you did the best that
you could give him what you had
so if you're gonna say hey I can either
not make a video because it's not
perfect or I can make a one minute video
with everything else going on but it
won't have to structure
I'd rather you make the one minute video
okay
I I did record them I just didn't post
them uh yeah all of them and I did write
notes so I would like to go in it you
know after all
post and then recognize now if it's a
year later and you're still
here that's a problem right so like
there's a grace period and grief is real
right but if it's three years later and
you're still in grief and you still
can't do anything then that's that's a
bigger problem that we need to to work
through but for the most part I think of
all the negative emotions
you know if you think positive emotions
like courage and ambition and drive and
service and all that and negative
emotions of of fear and anger and
jealousy and all of that
every negative emotion I want to try to
eliminate from my life except for grief
grief is a special one
like I don't want to have jealousy in my
life I don't want to have anger or or
um any of the like strong negative
emotions but grief not that I want grief
in my life but it's it it just has to be
worked through
like if I'm jealous about somebody I
don't want to work I want to fix it and
get rid of it I don't want to be jealous
of other people but grief you can't just
get rid of it like if you dive into your
work
it's still there
you know you can't just forget about it
and so you have to work through it and
time will heal and you won't be as
productive as you could be normally
would be and that's fine there's a
little bit of Grace I think all of us
and if you haven't had any grief yet
it's it's gonna happen at some point I
mean it's just the Human Experience oh I
I did I did have it and of course I
still go to to syrupy like two times a
week for my ankles so you know it's
juggling with limited amounts of energy
but I I also noticed that I really want
to continue on with the business the
drive is there
so release make your one minute videos
and release it
okay thank you
if you want to get a copy of build to
serve and join us live for our next
training with me to
meet actions you can go get the book
right there next to me right there I'll
see you there I'll see you to get the
book it's a good one much love